Monster Hunter generations for the 3ds
this is the 17th monster hunter game for
the 3ds system I'm just making this but
not that many come out in the u.s. like
we we've had a very limited number
because generally they've played it very
smart that they've have seen that it's
not as popular so like in Japan you'll
have monster hunter than Monster Hunter
ultra and in Monster Hunter super ultra
like kind of like Capcom does with the
Street Fighter games but for like
Monster Hunter 4 the only one we got was
monster 104 ultimate and that was the
best version of it the one with the
hardest monsters in Japan they had
Monster Hunter 4 and then for ultimate
and generations is is not a full Monster
Hunter game in some ways like this is
definitely not Monster Hunter 5 it
builds a lot of of Monster Hunter 4
ultimate it both in the way that it
plays in the battles that you go through
and the things that it introduced the
game let's get a little overview of the
Monster Hunter series you know we've
already talked about how it's very
popular in Japan I mean this year's
could exist entirely in Japan and still
be massively successful but they bring
it across the sea ocean every couple
years but Peter monster hunter in your
world you're you haven't hunted you know
monsters at quite as diligently as
Justin hey old I'm not sure many of us
have yeah no not really at all but uh
but in terms of the sort of the niche
that you see this game fitting in terms
of you know it begs comparisons to Dark
Souls and stuff what's what's the
monster all about from my perspective
Monster Hunter is a very hardcore game
one that is unapologetically difficult
and difficult to penetrate as well like
to really understand not just what to do
but how to do it in a way that is
efficient but fun and that's always been
my problem with these games is I I see a
lot of promise and I always want to get
into it about half hour and I'm like
questioning everything and there's not
really a good answer for it but that
doesn't necessarily make these games bad
I mean they're clearly beloved you love
these games that they always get great
scores because there is a tried-and-true
system within them that works really
well I just wish that they could find a
way to broaden their her eyes
and it sounds like they haven't managed
to do that yeah it is not a
pick-up-and-play experience if you just
want to jump into a game it is not like
that Zelda level of oh I know exactly
what I'm doing all of the items that you
get are like represented by icons and
it's it's really just getting
familiarity with things when you've
played the game for many iterations like
that because that that is a shorthand
for what the things that you need but
even those just really aren't organized
that well it's a very old-school way of
organizing but I think the bigger
problem that it has is that it is
terrible at tutorial izing right how to
play it when you get into the game yeah
it's weird that even when they're
explaining how to play something they do
it with a lot of text like you're gonna
read this and then at some point they'll
say well I'm not gonna explain
everything we there's an in-game menu
just go through that and read the rest
of it but there are ways to learn it and
even what I've done when I want to learn
something new about it I go to YouTube
there are so many people who've spent
hundreds and hundreds of hours playing
these games and they have great
resources it's still a lot to go through
like there is a I think gaijin hunter I
would throw out a little bit of a plug
too he does like 20 25 minute videos on
each individual weapon and how to start
out on them and they are amazing
tutorials that read that once you go
through them it makes the game more fun
you're like oh I understand how this
works and how to use it in what kind of
situations it but the problem is that
you have to do that outside of the game
to get that enjoyment and at what point
I mean you have to get to a point of
familiarity with the game where that
tutorial even makes sense right the
tutorials especially since Monster
Hunter 4 ultimate I think they've done a
good job of getting you into the basics
it's not always the most fun but
understanding how the world is laid out
what you need to do on a hunt
but the difficulty can ramp up very
quickly and kind of like Peter was
saying like there there is that Dark
Souls element where when you go up
against a boss he doesn't have a glowing
red spot it's not the Legend of Zelda
and it says you need to hit me here I'm
going to be invulnerable all of the
other times until I show that and then
hit me now he's just a like it's just
like a big monster and you need to
figure it out like by watching him and
observing and running around when is a
good time to hit him where is a good
place to hit him how am I gonna survive
this encounter
like me you try very hard to figure it
out for yourself and then you just end
up dying and saying well I've got better
games to play well I had a good run yeah
but I really want to know I mean I know
a little bit cuz I've read your review
but what you know what what is it about
this series that does make it so good
that does make it such a have such
lasting appeal I it's I think it is
multiple things part of it is the social
aspect and that's the thing I think
that's always made it catch on better in
Japan is that you have a more tight-knit
group who and you're gonna be playing on
the train there's a chance like with
Pokemon go that you're gonna run into
someone else who's playing that game and
you can actually just get together and
go on a hunt if this has that install
base that has that broad appeal at that
you are able to encounter people
casually and that's we just don't have
that here yeah but co-op multiplayer is
a huge part of that series and
especially on the 3ds and it's so much
it's so much fun to play with somebody
else to work together towards a common
goal but the other thing that it has
that's also very in the MOU like is that
aspect of collecting when you fight a
monster it's gonna drop some rare piece
of loot and you you have to collect a
whole bunch of them and sometimes it'll
be something that'll let you put
together a really cool-looking piece of
armor I mean Eric Tabak in the the back
running the cameras for this he he knows
about that pull of collecting armor for
destiny for World of Warcraft and
Monster Hunter even though it's on a
smaller system gets you in that same way
you're like oh I if I spend a little bit
more time I can get this really cool
helmet my carrot can be super powerful
that's what I want to ask that like do
you feel like this series is like
languishing because it sits on the 3ds
because it's not like a PlayStation 4
game it's not you know this you know
you're even a PC game for that matter
you know I feel like PC would be a
really great home for the Monster Hunter
series but at the same time it doesn't
have that same appeal like if there were
Monster Hunter 5 you you always have
that I think feeling that once a series
gets along to a certain number maybe
then it's unapproachable because I
haven't played Monster Hunter 1 through
4 fact would that hurt it more to like
maybe a complete rebranding kind of like
what Dark Souls did blood-borne yeah
like it makes those feel like they are
standalone experience it's not even they
just don't feel like that you don't feel
like oh I have to have played the other
games to really get into that like
Monster Hunter annex or something good
good nxy well index is an untried if
we'll have to see I know
well yeah but I want you to speculate
like imagine you know with all the
things we're talking about the potential
for a mobile you know components of this
to then be able to bring it home and get
like a better version of the game
potentially depending on whatever the
healthy index is yeah something
something that does tie in to kind of
like how Pokemon go ties in to your
real-world experiences like I think
anytime you get an app that will tie
into playing the actual game that's
always fun and a little bit exciting for
me because it feels like oh I'm getting
something out of this like imagine if
the next Pokemon game uses some element
of Pokemon go you're able to bring in
items or bring in Pokemon and or somehow
interact with your game Monster Hunter
if it was able to do something like that
I feel like that would help lower that
barrier to entry like you have a
free-to-play version of this that gives
you something well if I go and try out
the real game I can bring that over and
it'll help me out a little bit but as it
stands the barrier to entry for Monster
Hunter generations still pretty high
probably want to put in like tech you
don't want to give up after the first
twenty hours is on that first twenty
after that it's really smooth so it's a
big ass but like you said there are
resources out there for to help and you
know we were lucky enough that if you're
watching this show you have access to
those resources because internet but in
terms of generations let's say someone
got a kick out of ultimate or you know
gave ultimate a try I mean is this for
people who are like yep like don't film
it want more Monster Hunter that seems
like it's pretty squarely in that target
zone yeah it's something that is going
after that established fanbase if you
played for ultimate this is a natural
thing to get a little bit more of that
monster 100 hook if you haven't played
for ultimate I would probably recommend
that one a little bit more over this one
they're both excellent because they're
both at that at the core about hunting
monsters for ultimate has a more
interesting story built around it where
as generations kind of ignores the story
and just go straight for killing big
monsters are there any people in the
Monster Hunter world that are like
remember that story about journey there
was this group of people I think there
were like senior citizens or something
who would just go and into journey and
guide new players through like that was
their thing they would just wanted to
play with new players and like
experience it with them and be like you
know guides is there like a crew of
Monster Hunter people that will do that
same thing okay all right like let's go
hunt them monsters noobs yeah that'll be
your guide like most of memos I think it
has a very strong community of people
who just want to help the the fanbase
grow and to help you get into the game
but at the same time when you're playing
the gig you don't have voice chat so
that makes a little bit of a barrier
between that yeah so there's a little
bit of a reigning it in too much all
right well if you want a challenge and
you want to get into one of the most
popular games in Japan and one more
longer running series and Monster Hunter
generations is out now on the 3ds
garnered an 8 on GameSpot go read Justin
hey walls review see the hits for you